this is from The New York Times this is
from about a year and a half ago yeah as
a woman was raped train riders failed to
intervene police say and this was just
the first story I was able to pull up
about five years ago now I think it was
five years ago I did a video on my main
Channel men are refusing to help women
and children it got millions of views
and it was just like this 15 minute
thing of me talking about there were a
handful of stories one
a woman was on a train and some guy
started getting in her face schmoozing
on her and being really aggressive and
no man would intervene and then she was
really angry and she was like why
wouldn't any man stand up for me well
there's a lot of reasons why they won't
do it another story I read years ago
this may be like 10 years ago now at
this point a guy was in a store and he
there was a there was a journalist who
was in a store saw a child crying with
no parent seemingly lost and they and
she said I saw a man walk up walk
towards this kid looking at the kid
concerned then stopped looked around
turned around and walked away
they ran up to the child like this
person and got a security guard to help
the person and then the reporter said
she then ran to the man and asked him
why he turned around and didn't help the
kid and the man said because I would be
accused of having kidnapped that kid and
I don't want to be involved
that is a crazy prospect that we have
this story from Philadelphia where a
woman was being raped on the train in
front of people and what did they do
most of them just leave me alone some of
them started filming no one did anything
there's a lot of reasons why men are
outright refusing to help women one I
think some men have disdain for for
modernity that we we're in this era of
toxic masculinity is toxic toxic women
can do whatever they want and you know
without without consequence that's how
they feel I'm not saying it's true and
so you'll get a guy who's probably
watching him and be like screw him I
don't care not my problem whereas there
is an inverted there I was just watching
um the imitation game about Alan Turing
and uh it's it's so it's such a BS
because he didn't he didn't crack Enigma
I was reading up on it was like some
Polish guy actually who did but he built
the machine but anyway they he's trying
to recruit this woman and she's like it
would be indecorous of me to come and
work for his majesty because it would be
around men and so then he's like you can
work and be in the women's dorms and
then he can't go to her place because
he's a man that's the alternative right
a society where the men and women are
separated when the men are
overprotective you get that when the men
feel like they're not allowed to protect
women and children they'll be punished
imprisoned or insulted for being
masculine you get the inverse is there a
happy medium or what do you guys feel
about this I'll just I'll just say like
someone super chatted we're not allowed
to protect women and children anymore so
why would we and I'm like what can I say
to that yep and your cops don't even
protect maybe
um women have given off an impression
that we don't want to be protected or
loved or looked after maybe that's the
problem and maybe it should be up to
each woman what is the best for her I
think that's important but like I've
come out and said it like I want to be
protected I want to be loved I don't
want to be out here doing this alone I
don't want to be fighting these demons
and ghouls alone like it sucks I'm
scared I actually am scared I'm scared
I'm gonna get killed I think a lot of
people have a problem facing that
darkness and they choose to just turn
away I think a lot of uh our society
again we promoted like widespread a lot
of fathers yeah tell me they can't look
they can't look at what I'm thinking
about what I'm talking about when I'm
posting but I I don't want to you struck
something in me Tim and I don't want to
forget it I I do understand why people
are very skeptical of these stories you
should be a little but not to the point
where you harass survivors what can I do
as a Survivor as a public Survivor and
as an advocate to at least
maybe convey the story better I don't
know what I can do to make people
believe people don't believe my story
they did evidence yeah just getting what
evidence and are are survivors supposed
to bring because it's like we bring
evidence and it's always not enough well
you know it's never enough it's like
always something well look look at look
at uh Amber Heard okay she she writes
this op-ed where she it's vague and you
know she has this narrative that Johnny
Depp is the bad guy
and then the full story kind of comes
out and it's like well they're both kind
of ish heads to each other but she was
definitely being abusive towards him and
so what happens is you have this
long-standing it's been a a decade or
longer the you know believe all women
and are our legal systems built upon
innocent until proven guilty and the
right to confront your accusers yes so
immediately people take issue with
Anonymous accusations without evidence I
mean that's especially with Julian
Assange being falsely accused that that
pissed off a lot of people especially
anti-war movement because then they
dropped it and it was fake to begin with
and they used as an excuse to lock this
guy up for a decade and prevent him from
doing his work Assange was accused of
rape a lot of people don't know this no
no he wasn't even accused of rape it was
like it was it was it was but that's
what the corporate media ran with it's a
corporate media ran with Julian Assange
rapist you know that that was a huge
story that of course uh allowed the
general public to be like yeah he's
guilty yeah maybe he should be in jail
and then they put him up in solitary if
they have to run away if if this story
about the train in in the New York Times
here's the problem
if a guy on that train grabbed the man
who was raping that woman and stopped
him
then he would probably get arrested in
church yeah he would yeah he would
but I think what's important is that
we're having this conversation right and
and I I actually I have a question for
the audience that's um I got a question
I can phrase this for you guys
put a one in the chat
if if you
would attack the rapists to stop him
knowing you would get locked up in jail
and put a two in chat if you would not
want to risk your freedom in life for a
random woman
did that work did that did that make
sense yeah I think that's good question
actually I think the truly masculine the
real masculine is a man saying let them
let them come I'm not letting this man
hurt this woman that's that's in line
with the come and take it you will try
to aggress upon me you will try to
infringe upon my rights but I will stand
firm on what I know to be true but
there's gonna be a lot of people who are
maybe more cynical and I know you mean
this in this disrespectful way because I
can understand it where they're like
dude if they if if they want to keep
advocating for this and voting for it if
seventy percent of millennial women keep
one of voting be voting for these
policies why would I go to jail for them
when they asked for it and I mean like
ask for the policies not obviously to be
attacked so one of my rules is that uh
I'm not so no it's split in the chat
it's ones and twos sometimes I want to
uh so it's difficult as a human to hear
some of these stories especially about
children and not want to seek vigilante
justice so I understand those who do but
I am of no use if I'm in prison or
jailed because I decided to go out on a
freaking LARP and do things the you know
whatever way but so it's like you're
you're on a train and a guy grabs him
and throws her down yeah and he's on the
train raping her and and there is people
saying like if I intervene not only will
I get hurt but I'll get arrested I'm not
doing it that's crazy to me it like
maybe I'm wrong I've never seen a sexual
I mean I don't well let me make sure I'm
not uh I don't think I've ever said I've
never been in that situation so it's
really difficult
to know what you would do I mean does
this gentleman have a knife does he have
a gun like is he whack I mean what are
we talking you know this is why I'm an
anarchist because number one
I'm serious I'm serious this is an
argument to be made here it's not a
perfect argument but the police are slow
to respond right this happened in
Philadelphia where people can't defend
themselves if a woman was able to have a
gun and be able to defend herself these
larger sexual assault crimes these large
rapes wouldn't be happening as much as
they are happening mainly because a lot
of women are left defenseless and the
one way to have this equalizer is to
allow people to be able to defend
themselves which is illegal in places
like Pennsylvania which is absolutely
crazy but
um again there's been so many instances
of police officers watching people
getting stabbed getting hurt and just
not doing anything not responding I just
wanna I wanna add too uh in terms of the
chat and the super chats the debate the
people who disagree with you but other
people who are making other points
I I'm really digging this like everybody
who's commenting saying you're wrong I
disagree everybody who's commenting
saying I can't believe people wouldn't
help her everybody who's saying like you
know how could you if the machine is
going to come against you and this is
what they're voting on that like I think
the discussion absolutely is just is
just fantastic so but it's good it's
good that we're having these
conversations uh talking about it is
better than and also one of the things
that I love is when you think through
these situations before you're actually
in one because these are all things that
could happen
to you in real life it's not a movie
this is not a test so you should be
thinking through in advance what you
would do uh and too much to what uh Luke
was just saying I am a fully armed
Survivor of human trafficking no two
ways about it no no no discussion yeah
absolutely so and I encourage pardon no
we're not going to talk about all that
but uh more personal Liberty and more
ability for human beings to be able to
defend themselves equally against
criminals who will always have firearms
and weapons it took me a while to get
there I had a conversation with ma story
because I was always very scared of guns
and this is great oh yeah he's he's
great isn't he
um and I had a conversation with
Monastery and my mom and I went and we
got uh geared up for her 60th birthday
so it was really fun but um and now I
feel very empowered and um and I feel
ready I just don't want to be abused
again or any have anything happen and I
feel like that's the only great
equalizer and training don't forget to
train you have to train part of it too
you know yeah that's part of it too you
know what you know the terrifying
reality I think is
the people in these cities like
Philadelphia would prefer more rape
victims and less dead rapists
and there's an interesting idea there I
don't want anyone dead but think about I
was thinking about this in terms of guns
if this woman on the train had a gun
even like a Derringer with like a you
know 22 in it or something this guy
would have gotten off her real fast and
and he'd probably survive but there's a
reality that one a woman should be able
to protect herself if a man is trying to
to take her she could she should I
believe she should be allowed to use
whatever Force necessary to protect
herself from that man but this would
mean that man dies
now the left's argument you see it all
the time there was like uh I can't
remember the story but there's been a
bunch of them where a guy was like
breaking into someone's house and he got
shot and killed and they go you didn't
have to kill him you know you could have
let him victimize you and then it's just
like why is it incumbent upon the victim
to assume they're going to survive the
attack instead of using whatever Force
they can to try and survive the attack
so so the the logic of the left on this
tends to be they would rather the the
rape victim get raped and survive
because it means both people live then
the woman not get raped but then kill
somebody you see what I mean
like that that's their logic
okay there was there was a guy like Rob
the liquor store and then he got shot
and killed and they were like but you
didn't have to kill
and the guy's like he came in with a gun
to my liquor store I thought I was gonna
die no he was just robbing he was just
robbing you this is the sad reality I
don't want anybody to know yeah you
don't know until you're in that
situation and if it's a life or death
situation and it could be and it very
well could be you don't know what level
of insanity you're dealing with I don't
want to live in a world where it's the
victim's fault or responsibility for
having been attacked I think if you are
being victimized you have a right to
defend yourself with whatever Force you
have available to you and I think you
have a right to keep in bear arms that
means in this circumstance that rapist
would have died and that and that I got
I gotta be honest I don't like this guy
or had not shut off for sure or
seriously injured I don't want him
injured look I want him stopped and if
the only way to stop him because because
women have less muscle mass less bone
density is to be armed and that means
this guy gets shot I would rather the
woman not be raped and this guy gets
stopped but it is it is horrifying to be
like there's an end result where someone
gets hurt well you know what don't
attack people because it is your fault
my view is if you're a rapist who
attacks a woman and then you get shot
you should be criminally responsible for
the that bullet to yourself because you
initiated the aggression and with how
incompetent police officers are or lazy
when it comes to Prosecuting or actually
getting actual Justice here that that's
that's going to be maybe one of the sure
ways to actually get some kind of
redemption here if it's real if you are
committing a crime
and then someone dies in the process of
that crime you the criminal responsible
so for example you and a friend are
let's say uh guy a and guy beat rob a
liquor store liquor store clerk shoots
and kills guy B guy a in many states
will get charged for for that like
there's other circumstances too probably
a better way to describe it is if you're
in the act of committing a crime and a
bystander has a heart attack and dies
they will charge you for you know in
many states interesting my view of this
if you are a so I don't care who the
person is if you are a criminal and
you're attacking a woman or or anybody
and then you get shot you should get
charged with aggravated assault with a
deadly weapon even though someone else
shot you you started it it's your fault
maybe that's a little aggressive but I
don't know if if the law has actually
stopped the crimes I actually just kind
of feel like if these cities allowed
people to keep in bear arms I actually I
think Philadelphia is not good but
Pennsylvania tends to be
ain't nobody's gonna attack a woman if
they know she's strapped yep but they're
promoting lawlessness to not have to be
strapped yeah but but that would be nice
I agree like but I know it's not Utopia
and I can't live in like yeah I get it I
mean there are evil people in the world
regardless of what happens or whatever
laws put in place you have to be
prepared to defend yourself and even 200
years ago it was Bears wolves coyotes
yeah there was always danger but in and
capistan and capistan there always is to
be a little different I mean there's
nothing getting rid of danger I mean bad
people will always find a way to happen
did you ever see that video Luke we
probably talked about it where the guys
playing the game city-states have you
ever heard this yes we talked about this
so many times and it proves what I've
talked about for a very long time it's a
video game so it's real life okay it's a
video game where you build a city-state
buildings factories Apartments housing
Etc and you set policies more taxes
lower taxes more authoritarian with
police less and so this guy
um I think you guys are I don't know who
he is because it's such a good video
he's like I'm gonna get rid of all
government no taxes just let everything
go crazy it's going to be a crime ridden
hell hole There Was So eventually he's
like wait what's happening there were
ski resorts everywhere there was 0
poverty everything was a skyscraper
every citizen was super wealthy and he's
like what's going on how is this
happening there's like no government
thank you
can we try this experiment once I mean
and even when it was practiced somewhat
like in Singapore or in Hong Kong
especially with the larger Financial
ramifications of a laissez-faire kind of
government we had that we had Prosperity
we had so much people progressing and
getting wealthy and getting rich and
helping each other and so much less
poverty whenever the government doesn't
intervene and when they do they're just
acting like thugs they're just acting
like gangsters getting a cut of their
money screwing everyone else over and
this is why I think the biggest enemy
towards humanity is big government and
we should always try to be pushing
against it as much as we can that's
still possible with like the population
we have now who is so like subservient
there's gonna be a messy period where
there's going to be a lot of people
winning Darwin Awards but maybe they
deserve to win Darwin Awards right no no
let's be real all right let's be real
like would you rather have people when
Darwin Awards or would you rather have
uh you know the federal government use
your tax dollars in order to send small
children to private islands so so uh
people could go there and do something
else what's the less there of two evils
um you know Waging War nuclear Holocaust
we could we could get into bio weapons
we could get into it what's the lesser
of of two evils what's what's going to
lead to less harm in my personal opinion
what I'm describing I I just wanna I
wanna stress this again like the people
who are chatting super chatting arguing
and very defensive of Tate the people
who are there's less critical of them I
just got to say like I feel like this
discussion is one of the best
discussions we've had on a variety of
issues to be completely honest like
again agreed with all of the people who
are disagreeing and arguing and
defensive or against like this is this
this feels substantive no I and I love
the conversation this is the thing that
people don't realize about me
regardless if it's good or bad or if
people are talking trash on me or
talking about my story or whatever I'm
just happy we are having these
conversations we used to live in a time
where a Survivor if they wanted to
release a statement would have to wait
for the corporate press to care and then
green light it for to maybe be in the
back of the New York Times now I'm a
Survivor of human trafficking who served
survivors came up here on Independent
Media told you folks and now it's out to
many people and we can all talk about it
but we're still talking about you know
human trafficking domestic violence sex
abuse child abuse child sexual abuse
material we are talking about these
things and let me tell you it makes
Predators Big Mad Predators down bad and
abusers down bad and that's the way it
should be you know I think that before I
was searching for this answer like well
where are the men well maybe it's you
gentlemen here giving me the platform to
have the conversation so that we can
keep the conversation going and other
survivors don't feel alone maybe that is
what men are doing and maybe I wasn't
seeing uh the full vision well men
should also be protecting women in
public as well thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time